can we please stop saying that it's not
true men are not intimidated by strong
women like men are turned off by women
that misuse their strength to fight
against them instead of building with
them but it's weak men who can't handle
strong women and when I say strong I'm
not talking about the all my life I had
to fight type of women women that are
proud uh to be able to weather struggle
storms and tolerate mistreatment and you
know they don't ask for help even though
they deserve help and should be asking
for help I'm not talking about that type
of strength we ain't promoting that over
here I'm talking about the type of
strength where a woman is expressive
about her boundaries she's certain in
her identity